have you heard anybody try to make an AI
version of yourself yet
no I'm waiting it's gonna happen yeah
I'm weird I want to hear it though like
yeah actually crazy like can AI nail
your your tone you know
I mean ain't nothing some others crazy
[__] they are Ellen Rihanna Kanye the
Rihanna Tim's remix that [__] crazy it's
fire yeah
I seen some other [__] it was a
I think it was Kanye Franco Kanye single
Frank Ocean joke no Kanye's under Justin
Bieber jump
yeah that [__] was crazy though
yeah it's kind of crazy the AI thing is
getting a little it's getting a little
sketch I hope they I hope they shut that
[__] down though they're not going to
the labels are going to start [__]
doing the same [__] the actors are doing
you see why the actors are on strike
yeah cause they're trying to slide in a
little artificial intelligence into the
movies yeah so like extras like they
want the extras to be like AI like they
want to be able to scan like an actor
and then use their artificial likeliness
school is coming bruh [__] [__] man go
that [__] just be a few more years
I think some bull made a song like Drake
featuring The Weekend that [__] hit like
a million the first time oh yeah yeah
this was like yeah this was like what
maybe like six months ago seven months
yeah it was recent and that [__] was
that [__] went viral they like this [__]
hard because it's like also not a bad
idea if you're a writer I wonder if it's
a terrible idea to like writers on there
right now writer's doing all AI [__]
cause like this is what this is like let
me send this out so like my thing is if
you're a writer and you write a song for
Drake do you send the AI Drake version
to his team so you're like look this is
how he would sound I've seen some [__]
like I I don't link with somebody they
got some [__] I can imagine man like
they're not even writing they ain't
voice no more are you uh your your
process you're are you straight Melody
then punch in or yeah yeah I'm Melody
punching in yeah or Melody and just
think and punching Pro Tools guy when
you're recording yourself logic yeah wow
we just this guy just switched over to
logic right here
he loves life
I'm a lodging guy I've been online I
heard logic is the [__] though the [__]
I've been on there for like 10 years and
you don't need a license you don't need
a [__] little USB thingy yeah logic a
lot much Logic the one much easier to
get cracked yeah yeah yeah I got a [__]
here Cricket if you're interested in
this in stealing software logic much
easier to steal than Pro Tools no for
sure 100 man
um all right so the album's coming out
when
August 25th that's very soon yeah that's
two weeks away three weeks away [__]
what do you say the seventh in like
three weeks what is today bro the 11th
I don't even know today today's the
fourth holy [__] dog I see like my whole
life yeah I have no idea what's going on
anywhere today's the fourth all right
yeah three weeks away the debut album
I'm very excited for it debut album man
yeah uh a lot of people looking forward
to this man I don't know it's gonna
touch a lot of people too bro have you
picked the next single yet obviously the
Chris Brown song is going crazy but have
you guys picked the next thing or you're
gonna let the face we dropped another
one like we dropped a single two weeks
ago that was it that's when it comes to
you who's on there wasn't that one that
was just you okay I didn't hear that so
the Chris Brown jumped and we dropped
when it comes to you it's going crazy
right now the video is going crazy and
you know what's gonna happen when the
album comes out you guys are gonna see
them streams go up or whatever record
and that's usually I feel like that's
kind of the new way to
you throw out the singles and then you
put the album in that the fans kind of
gravitate towards yeah especially with
these bigger artists now the labels will
hit me and they'll be like hey which
song Do you like on the album that just
came out with no note like Utopia right
like no one likes Kpop probably the
worst song in the album I think you're
crazy it is the worst song on the album
it's not a terrible song I love Utopia
but it's like if you're gonna go with a
record you gotta go with the Meltdown
right
to each his own what's your favorite do
you like well first of all what are your
thoughts on Utopia
the great album great production
yeah I liked it yeah I I like it yeah
what was your what's your album of the
year so far this year besides you can't
say great question don't say yourself
album of the year
I'm gonna go on my phone
because the narrative is it's been a
pretty rough year for music it's been a
crazy year not the best year
[Music]
hip hop is like like you said it's been
I don't feel like [__]
[__] not focused no more how they used
to be like that's why in my opinion the
best album of the year so far is killer
Mike's album I heard that she was crazy
and somebody played me that John too
it's a joint Andre 3000 on there killer
Mike's future hard yep Andre 3000. she
also worked on that album for like four
years so that's I mean listen based off
that song alone bro
production
Cadence real music bro and that's like
I'm saying like
that music is not being pushed in front
of the the [__] like he dropped the
album of the year I think he's doing
some rap [__] when I listen yeah but
it's like so much [__] be put in
front of our face the real music get
pushing it back bro like you know what
I'm saying so
I feel like [__] Gotta start
back I feel like back then bro
all the all the um the [__] that was put
in front of our face it has some like
it's structure to us right right you
know what I'm saying like 50 Cent these
[__] was making hooks that everybody
could sing bro like listen I want to get
your take because you're a songwriter
right I I feel for whatever reason right
now like the women in hip-hop are like
the only people who are really kind of
applying themselves and trying to make
real records and I don't know if that's
because
you know they're in with more riders or
they they're they're trying I just feel
like women are making the most palatable
records with structure with hooks with
like Melodies like it just
I feel like they're really running
circles around uh male artists right now
in terms of just like when you turn the
radio on like I didn't have it anyway
yeah yeah like the chicks are killing it
I should just shout out to sexy red
don't uh she having no way like
I I think they killing it more because
they being themselves type [__] they're
not trying too hard
being them and just you know what I'm
saying even you they raw version of
themselves and I also think women are
very like uh for whatever reason a lot
of women artists are like extremely open
to like bringing in help for melodies
for hooks I'm not saying for verses but
you know no men are and you the [__]
is too
yeah I mean but you can't you just can't
hear it in in the songs anymore yeah
because [__] is just rapping
like three minutes and you're like wait
where's the [__] you like oh that's the
hook like oh bro these [__] just
making these [__] a rap a whole song
and just make the song title as
something they said in the song they
always got no hook and then the hook is
just like it sounds like an extension of
a verse and then when you hear it back
again yes and it's the laziest [__]
whatever they said in the verse Oh my
God they will name the title of the song
oh it's the [__] bro we need a new we
need a new age 50 Cent bro we need
something this [__] 50 Cent made hooks
you sure did Ja Rule Nelly you know yeah
man hooks bro like so when you in the
club everybody's singing that hook bro
like that [__] that's why I think
Hip-hop not where it needed to be right
now bro I agree with you man people
gotta start making records again yeah
yeah shout out to uh to everybody out
there trying though you know I mean look
Friday the album comes out on August
25th yeah which is also a Friday
sure would only be right your album
comes out on a Friday well all albums
come out on a Friday but we're gonna act
like this is on purpose you know back in
the day on a Friday if it came down on
Tuesday we still the joke and look at us
filming this interview on a Friday sure
Jesus you know like we're super woke and
all that shit's lining up and there's
some sort of hidden meaning in that and
we're gonna decipher and let the fans
kind of figure out how Illuminati is
involved in this interview Friday
dropping I'm on Friday while being
interviewed on a Friday all right there
it is man appreciate you brother all
right boom